son gouvernement la parole est à
monsieur thierry robert seul président
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
la ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie
après une semaine de paralysie de la
réunion le mouvement de grève qui avait
cours à la société réunionnaise de
produits pétroliers srpp a pris fin hier
ce blocage total de lille a une nouvelle
fois été révélateur de la vulnérabilité
de notre département
face à cette situation monopolistique
accepté pourtant la srpp a quasiment une
mission de service public
ne parlons nous parlons là d'une
entreprise créée grâce à des fonds
publics
début 2012 j'avais déjà proposé que
l'état et les collectivités locales
mettent en place un cadre institutionnel
qui leur permettent d'être acteurs et
décideurs au sein de cette entité
la fin du monopole de la spp est une
décision qui doit être prise
rappelons que ces propositions ont été
partagées par l'ensemble des acteurs
lors d'un débat organisé par le préfet
en 2012 elles n'ont toujours pas trouvé
écho cette entreprise bnf privée
bénéficie d'une convention d'occupation
temporaire du domaine public
kiko jusqu'en 2030 et d'une régulation
tarifaire des équipements s'y trouvant
sa situation de monopole qui s'y
agrègent ne fait que légitimer l'idée
d'une nouvelle gouvernance du stockage
des hydrocarbures à la réunion le tout
automobile devient un risque
insupportable pour notre île et la mise
en place d'un réseau de transport
collectif n'utilisant pas les énergies
fossiles à la réunion est une impérieuse
nécessité
je souhaiterais donc soumettre à votre
avis la solution prospective suivante
serait-il souhaitable dans le cadre de
la transition énergétique de flécher une
part des quelques 260 millions d'euros
de tss est perçue par la région réunion
sur les grappes sur les hydrocarbures
vers un fonds dédié aux transports en
commun utilisant des énergies non
fossiles
la prise en otage des usagers ça suffit
la vision du tout voiture à la réunion
ça suffit pensons à l'avenir
suite à cette semaine de grève et face
au constat qui s'impose à nous le
gouvernement envisage-t-il la nouvelle
gouvernance de la sapmer gerber la
parole et à madame george pau-langevin
ministre d outre-mer merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député thierry robert
effectivement nous avons suivi avec
beaucoup d'attention ce conflit qui a
paralysé la situation à la réunion
durant un certain temps mais comme vous
l'avez dit il s'agit de conflits qu'il
conseille à une entreprise privée et par
conséquent le préfet de la réunion a
pris les mesures utiles pour assurer la
continuité des approvisionnements
il a été le garant efficace de l'ordre
public
mais je ne crois pas que nous puissions
aller beaucoup plus loin
d'autant que les emplois ne sont pas
menacés ni la pérennité de la société
par conséquent aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans un modèle d'économie réguler c'est
à dire que l'état intervient sur le
montant un des prix l'état intervient
aussi pour vérifier qu'il y ait une
juste rémunération de l'opérateur
mais pour autant je ne vois pas comment
nous allons pouvoir permettre à l'état
qui n'est pas actionnaire d'être présent
au conseil d'administration de cette
société privée donc là dessus on pourra
difficilement avancer
par ailleurs vous avez parlé des stocks
stratégiques et là encore aujourd'hui la
situation est sous contrôle et je ne
pense pas que nous ayons d'inquiétude à
avoir à ce sujet par ailleurs vous
soulignez et vous avez raison la
nécessité de développer le transport
durable à la réunion et dans les autres
mers
c'est effectivement la raison pour
laquelle dans les projets qui ont été
soutenues par le ministère
nous avons trois projets de bus à haut
niveau de service à la réunion et il n'y
aura 15 millions d'euros de subvention
par l'état pour soutenir ce mode de
développement
mais pour autant effectivement je ne
suis pas persuadé que nous puissions
aller beaucoup plus loin et par
conséquent aujourd'hui il appartient aux
collectivités locales de prendre des
mesures utiles pour flécher la taxe
spéciale sur la consommation vers
d'autres modes de déplacement